let's see are we live tom uh one sec
yeah we're now live pete okay
well i'll make it two o'clock
uh so we'll start anyway first of all
thank you
all for for coming and and turning up
and we shall go through this as best we
can
and anybody who's watching on youtube
well have a nice day but
uh so we'll get on with it apollo mary
where's mary no apology no apology all
right
okay no apologies
um minutes of the last meeting
i'll go through the the pages
um so page three
four five
six seven
and eight um
if everybody's happy with those minutes
could i have a proposal please
simon newton proposer secondo
councillor inch has got his hand raised
chair well okay i'll i'll take
council and manly okay see i could
i could see her first right can we go to
the vote
mary so please get ready with your
unmuting
are we ready yeah i think
okay abstain
counselor pumpkin
oh mr harper
or council range
for councillor langford
or councilor manley
or councillor newton
for councillor watson
thank you so i can sign that some
sometime in the future then mary
okay
all right move on item three action list
which is on page nine and ten
okay have a look minute 69 prestige
manager resources report that due to the
ongoing brexit
debate uh i think that is a
hello
pete yeah oh we can hear you we lost you
for a second
all right well there's there's some
some some faces not on here now why's
that
you've got a ball signal i would
anticipate
wow i checked it before i went on i got
about 38 meg
anyway okay they're coming back
was is steve there yes chad did you want
me
sorry because you froze i didn't know if
you asked a question so yeah
minute 69 steve so that this particular
item is just being delayed and delayed
so
you know expect a comprehensive
spending review towards the end of this
year although there have been
indications
that should it be a second wave of
coronavirus that would be delayed
until the start of next year so
currently
um we're not entirely sure when any of
this work
uh will form part of the system so we'll
respond
as and when it comes forward thank you
thanks steve chairman has his hand
raised
oh sorry okay yes peter
thank you chair is this on the action
points we're talking about
yeah we're on the lac we're on the
action list page nine and page ten
page eleven this is uh we are on page
nine at the minute peter
we'll get there in a minute thank you
yeah right minute eight
uh 7th of july 2020 that's been
completed
so that's done minute awesome
frozen again
for 1920 brunswick wars to include the
progress update to each qbr
email sent third of august okay
minute eight sent to do july 2020 qbr4
turrington pannier market to provide
additional information
uh about size of uppers flooding new
lighting painting etc etc
uh property and procurement manager
email sent
third of august as is the next one
um on housing
and the next one is on electric car
charging fees
um obviously um email has been sent
and the last one qbr4 electric car
charging fees senior solicitor
yeah chairman ac all right
so chair yeah on minute eight i've just
sent
to mary now um the the full off street
parking places order for distribution to
to all as committee members so that's
not just about the electric
charging that's about all of our
charging um
and fees and charges associated with car
parking so you'll have all of that
information
okay thank you right that's right
chancellor haynes encounters oh sorry
11 electric car charging uh tdcs
has no control over these areas sorry
can you remind me
we we found this out to a company do we
but we don't get any income benefit from
that
sean k can answer that yeah we yeah
stacey will cover it but i think it's
released the spaces
so okay stacy yeah we
they have at least some of those spaces
and we share in the income
that they obtain through the charging
points
right that's fine cheryl
yeah just say that i haven't had any
feedback it says that an email was sent
on the 3rd of august but as i understand
it that was
mary sent an email out but we haven't
actually received anything back
so we haven't had any information back
on our class
yes mary the notification where
the email was sent if you look at the
top of the column it says date contacted
it refers to the person responsible for
the action
completed would say email sent to or
counsellors or something so it's not
being completed okay
okay thank you right okay
anybody else on got the random no
okay we'll move on
public contributions well we we've got
no public
okay declarations of interest you all
understand about declarations of
interest and please declare
if if it's it's an item that you need to
declare
on okay agent matt has brought forward
with the permission of the chair i
haven't got any
but i will ask if anyone else has got
any
no okay item seven
obviously you want to get through this
very quick then
agreement we've got no no agenda for
part one
part two we've got no part two right
item eight which is this the qbr one
and it's on pages 11 to 46
um and okay who is going to start then
steve or david where'd david
i've lost him i was there chris
she's me pete oh yeah oh well okay then
right chris
okay we're just going to start with um a
short summary of the qbr highlights
and a look at the impact of kobe 19 on
torrance
which last three months so this first
slide their goal won
our economy uh the first thing that has
been the speedy payments of government
grants to local businesses
this was the stipulation the government
wanted us to pay the money quickly
and send the first tranche by easter we
were the sixth best in the country
so that was really good um
we have an ongoing commitment to support
our local businesses so we paid
99.20 have been paid on time as usual
um there's been good progress with the
future high street from bid
we work on the um globe and turnton's
gone ahead
with a viability study and hoping to be
able to get 100 pound grant
to take that further forward and we
managed to help with the safety opening
of our high streets
after the lockdown that's providing
guidance and advice
i'll go to healthier communities
the main thing there was our housing
options team maintained a really high
level of service during the lockdown
and we had to find a competition for 11
individuals who response to cover who
are homeless
they've also managed to find tank
accommodation for to 26
households during the hot time period so
they've been very busy but i've managed
to keep the service going
a couple of things to improve on there's
been no progress on empty homes at all
between the quarter and we've got low
numbers regarding delivery of homes
affordable homes
that's because the actual building
companies actually not been working
during lockdown
so seeing things start again now so
there's more in the pipeline
next slide please
go through the uh environments
some councils actually suspended some
waste collections during the lockdown
we kept all of our waste and recycling
going and we also kept our garden waste
collections going
so we managed to about 55 000
collections a week
the only thing we suspended was our oaky
waste collections
where they came back again in june so it
was a good service provided by waste and
recycling
um we have record levels of recycling in
the first quarter
57.3 again that's mainly due to glass
and cardboard
during the um lockdown period but you
know it's a really good success story
going on
we're like about you know 15 percent
higher than where two years ago
so it's really good yeah in terms of
goal four
effective uh customers council
our teaching did a really good job in
getting people working at home
at one point about 154 people working at
home
um any one time so i should keep most of
our services going with little
interruption
um the zoom technology was rolled out to
make this type of committee
viable at a distance there's been an
improved turn on employment applications
um it seemed like 99 percent of them
improved on time
um determined on time during the period
janet's team environmental protection
staff which is looks at increasing
their enforcement activities reduced
sickness level was an interesting one so
actually
staff sickness went down during the uh
pandemic
which is a bit perverse but um
we saw a lot of stuff redeployment
during the pandemic
so we actually moved people around to
make sure the service did continue
and we saw really good levels of
cooperation between the council and
other agencies
so it's actually good to see things
working together across devon
uh one downside they were beginning to
see reductions in the council tax and
business rate collection levels
so really that see an impact on that
from kobe now
and next slide please tom
this is just looking at the kind of
bigger picture for torridge and
the charts at the top there this is the
total deaths
no so this is the turtle confirmed cases
not deaths the total confirmed cases
from march
due to the both of august so entirely
there's been 56
cases confirmed of covered you'll see
that
the average kind of level in southwest
districts is four times as high as that
and the average for all english councils
is ten times as high as that
what i would say about the figures is
just looking at the totals obviously
torch has a low population density
so obviously areas with a high density
like cities would have a
more likely to spread the virus quicker
and also um
the more you test the more cases you're
buying and turrish haven't been lots of
testing
so obviously because rendering are
detesting our levels look lower as well
but you know it looks like we didn't
really run out of the uh that's
occurring 19 in terms of the impact on
our people
looking to the left up there you'll see
there's been a big impact on the local
economy
with nine thousand people furloughing
torridge which is more than one in three
of the workforce
so a big impact then also 72 percent of
our self-employed people have been
making income support claims
so a really big impact on our local
economy people who work here
if you look at the bottom now things
we've been doing to help
obviously we've paid our term 26 and a
quarter million pounds of the government
grants
as quickly as possible i think we're the
first second fastest in the country in
terms of speed
um we've knocked our systems ready to
make cash hardship payments so
people can apply i think 650 pounds
taking off their cash tax bills if
they're in hardship
we've also provided some money to local
town councils
help them support managing community
groups so we did everything we could in
terms of
helping british young people
this one here is looking at our actual
workloads and what i've done is
i've compared april may and june this
year with april may in june
2019 um obviously last year with the
customer home open
and we we get an average about 10 people
an hour through the door so that's being
closed
um so people are finding different ways
of conducting the council
there's been like an ongoing channel
shift for a number of years now
away from physical views towards digital
stuff but she's looking at the volumes
this last kind of three months
um do you see the telephone calls
slightly down
we actually made more calls with public
28 000
um emails has become our kind of number
one
where we get contacted so we received
200
thousand emails in the in the three
months so 32
last year we sent well we sent more
emails
you see internal emails went up 30
that's because people were
working remotely a big one there you'll
see we actually blocked one and a half
million emails
um increase of 72 so that's kind of spam
it's also
fraud attempts on the council in fact
back in february we had 1.2 million
emails blocked by rit team
when there's a kind of big fear about
coding we have more kind of
um scams and floor attempts um
so our tea team do a lot of work behind
the scenes stopping them getting through
it didn't we
the council's our firewall website hits
um almost six hundred thousand hits
during the theme one
thirty percent of last year and
obviously as a website improves we're
going to get more and more hits on the
website
and then at the bottom there just to say
that our our social media is becoming
more more important to the
communications team
so our facebook uh reach went to 150
percent
our tweet activity was 90 percent higher
and our instagram forms went to 73
and just kind of give you an example uh
words if you sent out a press release
you have to wait for some impact
last year we had the opening of the
subway and
in a few hours time where eleven half
thousand uh people reached on facebook
1500 people reached on tweet and 50
likes on instagram so it's kind of an
instant
reaching people quickly and effectively
if anybody's got any questions on those
speakers yeah anybody got any questions
for
chris
where's the dog we're just swapping over
pete
uh david's got a presentation now okay
mate okay
bear with me while i get to grips with
technology people thank you
get a grip oh no don't let me
presentation's gone must be down here oh
no
don't tell me the super presentation
there you go it's it's
it's on its way yeah okay
right okay so the final i just want to
first off i'll go through the
financial impact of covert as we
reported to cnr at the end of june
right and then update on where we are
now so where were we
on the 29th of june so
we had car parking income loss and
planning income loss i've just
flipped the button twice there by
mistake and we were forecasting a loss
on building control
land charges and licensing we're
predicting um less income
remember this is all while we're still
in lockdown and commercial income this
is income from our
premises that we rent out our industrial
units and office space we're predicting
shortfalls there
yeah short-term investments the bank of
england cut the base rate in march from
0.75 to
0.01 um and that meant that we would get
reduced income from our short-term
treasury
deposits and this other lost income
oh i've clicked the button too you've
been to today look at the button we also
expected some additional expensive the
additional expense we were expecting
would
under decode with additional i.t to
allow stock homework
um additional agency costs for richard's
team in refuge for back for people who
were self-isolated and we wanted to
take on more agency as um chris had
alluded to before we gave additional
support to our town and parish councils
we obviously had some additional
expenditure in homelessness because of
our increased uh responsibilities that
we had
um with covid and we spent additional
moneys on deep cleaning and additional
pp equipment
we're also anticipating a lost income
from council tax and less collection
because people are on furlough
having reduced income and perhaps were
prioritizing over debts over their
council tax debt
and we're obviously expecting some loss
of income from business rates
but then we'd did have some central
government support at that time in june
it was 727.000
has been confirmed support from central
government
so that left us with basically a deficit
of
2 million so where do we think we are
now
well our parking income loss is less so
we still think we're losing overseas
going to lose over 600 000 this year
well that's a big change from
losing over 900 000 and that's perfectly
explained by the increased visitor
numbers that we can all see
if we go to biddeford westwood or
appledore etc
uh we're still forecasting um having
significantly less money on our
interests that we get from our temporary
investments the bank of england base
rate hasn't changed and
what we can get when we deposit money
with the financial institutions is very
immediate indeed
also other issues have come out
contractual issues are rising from
covered 19.
um our members president have been at
full council and we know about our
issues with
leisure and uh grounds maintenance
um we've really looked at the council
tax deficit and actually i think it's
going to be a bit less than they
originally
forecast and we're averaging at the
moment about four percent down on our
council tax collection
rate than we would anticipate um the
actual number of claims for
local council task support haven't
actually increased marketably they're
about gonna
circa 2000 cases and we've seen an
increase of about
50 or 60 new cases uh what we
are conscious of is that furlough is
starting to unwind and then the true
picture will be known
because it's not from august employers
have to make a contribution to the
national insurance and pension
contributions for staff
from september they can only claim 75 to
the cost back
and still pay the employee employing
national insurance and
pension costs so as furlough unwinds i
think it ends in october we are
expecting increases in local planes for
local council tax support
because essentially people will lose
their jobs they won't return to work
but that i don't know the full extent of
that
we've revised our business rate deficit
and in very very simple terms the
government has extended
um retail relief so it's taken out a
vast wave of businesses
for 2020-21 from business rates
so we at the start of the year before
covid we were expecting to collect just
over 11 million pounds of business rates
we're now only actually charged with
collecting 4 million pounds of business
rates
we're compensated for that missing
element by central government grant the
actual business collate
business rate collection rate at the
moment is slightly above target
and i think that reflects that the so
the businesses are left with a liability
to pay
are preponderously in the public sector
rather than in the private sector
and they tend to pay up front at the
start of the year
um however and i'll come to the caveats
later there are issues regarding
business rates so
there's still a risk to the council and
i'll come back to that later
members be aware from part two we've
have a potential legal case so we've set
some money aside for the legal case
uh we do have as we've alluded to chris
alluded to homelessness related
pressures
these come from a variety of sources our
hostel isn't working at full capacity
because of social distancing and shared
facilities
we've had we've taken on more
responsibility because of in our cases
that we previously wouldn't have a
responsibility
for we've had to have a responsibility
for and it's also
a little bit more difficult to find
sustainable accommodation for people in
these times
you will have to apologize for my
verdict
flicky finger because i've clicked
things twice there uh we've also
make suggested making a contribution to
our property maintenance reserve because
we've got a backlog of maintenance
property maintenance that we need to
deal with
and we'd like to support uh apprentice
and trainee placements going forward
so we're just if you look there with
just about 1.8 million but here comes
the good news
sorry just uh so we said the court cost
him covered grants here so he takes up
to 1.8 million
we actually got funding from central
government for administering the
business support grants of 170
000 pounds um suffice to say we didn't
spend 170
000 pounds on administering those
business support grants it was basically
existing officers
there was a bit of overtime and one
officer worked full-time when they were
only working three three days a week so
our cost into administering the business
support grants is relatively minor
however we've got 170 000 pounds worth
of funding
we've also got um central government
coverage related grants
i've got another 129 000 since june
so which has helped and the big
announcement
was the central government announced
that it was compensated for our income
loss so we're estimating we're going to
get 500 000 pounds
for our income loss from lost car
parking visa etc
perversely as chris alluded to
i was forecasting in june that planning
income would be down i would assume that
there'd be uncertainty in the economic
market uh but actually what the reverse
has been complete this race we've never
been so busy
uh maybe people having all this time on
the hands has given the opportunity to
put planning applications we've also had
some significantly large plane
applications as well
so i was completely wrong on my
forecaster planning income towards the
end of june
dave could i just could i just make a
little statement here about planning
yes in one day last week
planning took 60 000 pounds in one day
through applications so we are doing
extremely well with planet yeah
okay sorry no no problem essentially
what i'm saying there just flicks on the
screen is
i'm forecasting a break-even position
now
right however there are caveats as they
always are with accountants
um what happens if there's a future
lockdown
well if there's another lockdown i
imagine we've seen some things in
the greater manchester area and
lancashire and west yorkshire
that could reduce our car parking income
initially so
there is a danger there's a future
lockdown in torridge
um second outbreak of covid that could
dramatically reduce our income
as we alluded to before the number of
claims for local council tax support
will certainly increase as furlough
unwinds but the scale of it is unknown
at this juncture
i really don't know i don't know is
furlough awaiting room for unemployment
or are people going to come back from
furlough and to a large degree go back
to their old jobs
time will tell but that day of reckoning
is coming as furlough ends
towards october
i alluded to earlier on that we're now
only collecting about four million
pounds worth of business rates and we're
being compensated by central government
for those business rates we can't
collect
however that's on the proviso the
business stays in business
if the business fails in the first
instance we would award empty relief but
where a business goes into
administration
no business rates are liable so some
colleagues
um in other councils with large retail
chains they will they'll bear this
impact
because they'll have to award empty
relief and then when if the company goes
into administration
they won't be able to collect any
business rates and there's no central
government
section 31 grant in that scenario
so we are vulnerable to businesses
failing
so um em and em and co that have failed
we may not be collecting business rates
from that they've actually not paid in
business rates at the moment when they
were in business
because we would have given them
extended retail relief them going out of
business
now causes a liability to the council
and of course the caveats uncertainties
what decisions we make as a council
in terms of supporting businesses say
through free car parking
support to the wider business community
support for the voluntary sector
and what decisions we make about
reopening our leisure facilities
so all these decisions will affect that
break-even position i previously
reported
um on the good news we've got on the qbr
report you'll see quite
large cash balances i think with
something in circa 20 million i believe
and just need to bear in mind that seven
million pounds of that isn't really our
money
that's the balance of the unspent
business support grants that is due back
to central government and they're
going to take that back at the end of
august maybe extend to the end of
september
um we have done a cash flow forecast for
torridge
and it shows us having a balance of
between two and three million pounds as
of march 2022
so we confidently forecast in depending
on some of those caveats i referred to
earlier that we will have sufficient
resources to
undertake our key responsibilities up to
march 2022
which i'd hesitate to say is probably
significantly better than most councils
at this juncture
uh i think you'll notice it wasn't a lot
of capital expenditure in quarter one
this has been delayed by the kovic 19
lockdown so the contractors were delayed
on getting
on site for the homeless hostel on the
high street and obviously there's been
issues assessing
homes for disabled facilities grant
adaptations and eco-flex energy
efficiency works
uh council watson we now go on to the
questions and answers i don't know if
you wanted to go through the questions
and answers and i'll just control the
screen which way would you like to do it
yeah well i'll i i can ask well
everybody
everybody must have got the questions
and answers so we'll go through it one
at a time david
yeah all right or do you want to do it
you can do it if you want david
it's your call you are the chair
you do it then okay okay so um
question one for me and harper when will
the economic strategies be ready
and there's a few questions there
there's the answers are on the next
screen
accepting the kovid 19 impacts on the
north devon economic structure when do
we feel this will be ready to implement
that's from
mr stephen dengate i've stated there's a
need to identify the impact of kovald19
as this will include self-employed but
also the current major losses at swallow
field and the appledoor shipyard that's
from mr harper
and better broadband recognizing the
reality and attraction of working from
all with north devon and also attracting
people to the area
and the demand for reliable fast
internet connection for delivering local
businesses across the storage
is there a possibility for the speed of
this development to process up and to
this development
to speed this development process or
what resources if anybody required for
this that's mr harper so
this the next slide is with the answers
he says
i'm gone is uh
oops i think i've gone i've gone too
okay
there's an answer there on the um
the broadband has anybody got any
comments absolutely i've missed
one of the answers there i'm afraid
everybody everybody
read the answers uh councillor hayes has
raised his hand chair
right okay what's my participants
yeah it's all right i've got it now
peter peter ames
when were they yeah what what are their
time scales involved in
rolling out this fiber scheme
please no did you hear me
oh god it's frozen
not everybody's frozen is david frozen
no no i'm just trying to
wonder what the time scale is for
rolling out this program
of fibre chair i can i can give you some
rough idea on that
it's um it's it's airbands
that have got the lot for of connecting
devin the somerset
program which is the rollout of super
fast broadband
um airband has stopped there there are
zones four to nine
um associated with lot four of the
connected dublin
somerset program zones four and five are
in north devon
uh six seven eight nine in torridge
they've started on
four already and all of them through
so our section of it should be done i
think it was
by the beginning of 22. yeah um
so over the next 18 months or so we'd
see the roll out of those
i i've come off a call with them
recently they're going to produce
to us under a non-disclosure agreement
so we might have to
distribute sensitively and
confidentially
to our members uh a programme of rollout
for our communities
the the idea for that mostly is is not
to see where we
will get a roll out of air brand
improvements but see where we won't
get a programmed of a band improvements
so that we can work with those
communities to find alternative
solutions
to maximize our coverage but i can talk
about distributing that when i know how
sensitive it is
and when we got it sean
who are you talking to at their band uh
it wasn't actually at a band i've been
talking to the devon somerset program so
airbander rolling it out for the
connecting devon sunset program
so airbander talking to devon county or
councilman somerset county council
and we're talking to the county i think
i think they've already started to roll
it down don't we
yeah i've been up in um uh north devon
they have
yeah and they're they've they're working
their way back down so they've started
up around the north coast
they're working down towards barnstable
and then it comes across our
district yeah that's right they're
coming all the way down here to broadway
would you
yeah yeah okay
next question then david
hello
david you muted dave sorry apologies
apologies apologies
um the next question was about the fish
stock and the cost of the fish stock
i've got provided with and without
central uh recharges
so the cost of the fish stock to the
council in 2019
20 was 7 700 pounds
and the cost in the first quarter of the
current year was 5400 pounds
but note that we paid the business rates
in advance
and hopefully on the next slide there's
a little table
and the when you include the central
recharges
the equivalent costs are fifty three
thousand six hundred ninety one and
twenty three thousand eight hundred and
sixty
so the recharges that you see there are
depreciation
and the when they see a negative which
says impairment revaluation must be that
the district value actually valued the
fish stock as
a greater value than we previously had
it and then central support covers
things like i.t finance hr
property services cost etc
uh the next question was about how long
the grant money that we had
to build the fish stock um
yeah did we have to pay it back well
apparently we fully according to paul
lopez stir our harvard master we fully
met that
and we've also fully met the terms and
conditions of the southwest development
agency which expired in
um november 2018.
i for something's gone wrong here i've
seen some questions i've got answers but
not questions so i do apologize
sean could you help us out on this
question please
which which one are you on number five
sorry i have this is somebody else's
mouse and it's super
on page five
as you're looking on the screen now
chris fuller's give an answer to
question five yeah
yeah come on sorry sean sorry sorry
david
i can only see what you can see so i
haven't got the question either i've
just got questions for chris's response
on the screen yeah right okay
we've got one here they from uh
lavish
no that that's that was the question
about how long the grant that we had
related in the fish stock before we had
to pay back what we said we no longer
have to pay
number five from chris fuller
first off the key what the key will be
working in partnership
etc etc yeah yeah you've got that
yeah yeah what i'm saying is i don't
have in front of me on the screen the
question can find the questions
no david that that there are no
questions um in looking at the original
schedule
sent out yeah and point four and point
five
so paul labster and chris fuller that
follows
there was no question beforehand so
you're not missing anything
okay so i'm not going mad thank you
council newton
okay um
there's a question here page 21
sorry yeah see there was some questions
there were some questions beforehand
okay
we're looking at where we're looking at
uh ian
well i haven't got it in front of me at
the moment um
i've just lost my thing i have if you if
you get if you scroll
back to to uh questions one to five
what they've done is they've they've
then covered all the
back page back page back page
i got
right hand stop i think i'm missing on
my slides questions four and five
councilor newton
yeah question four was
um
now i'm better broadband real no
i'll read it out um question four having
now left the eu
are we still constrained to the terms of
the grant to build the fiscal yeah
page 19 is the heading it's the next
block on
and then economic regeneration
unemployment figures growing
that's the one and that's what the
question five is that's what five is the
answer to
from chris fuller yeah okay
i actually raised the question regarding
the
um the use of the the estuary
and i had a reply from paul lobster that
they should be with the committees
my second supplementary question to this
is which committee
i'm a bit confused as to what council's
response was in relation to
um through the chair um the use of the
harbour and responsibility
i i i don't unders i'm not sure mr
harper i can't see the
the question if i if i chair if i i can
help i'm just
just reading through the emails that
came through so
um there was an estuary question
so estuary strategy identifies that
there's been no action plan as set out
in the
estuary strategy of 2014
if we have responsibility for the
foreshore although district balance
boundaries run down the middle should
tdc be addressing the current issues and
i think that was the question you put mr
harper
yes it was i can't find it anymore
correct
so chair i can give you a quick response
to that one now if you want that um
the the this i'm guessing has come about
in relation to the
use of the estuary for pleasure craft
and jet skis and things like that is
that is that what the concern is here
and
management of those problems yeah
correct right so we back in
back in 2014 when the uh estuary
strategy was produced
a full troll of all of our um powers and
responsibilities was done
by uh uk port advisors
and as firm solicitors from london
called lawrence graham
they took a look at what and how
what we were doing and how we were
involved with the management of the
estuary
and concluded that we have no
responsibility
for marine safety and we should try to
divest ourselves from
having any because you know the more we
get involved with
trying to manage craft on the estuary
the more we're taking responsibility for
what they do
we we're not resourced or equipped or
even have don't have the powers
to do that so we should step back and
that's exactly what we did
so one of the first things we did after
that was to get rid of the slipway
warden
in uh john churchfield's car park
who used to issue tickets for launches
on that car park
and basically what the only controls
there are
are through uh the voluntary code of
conduct which has been agreed
multi-agency approach uh ourselves
coast guard biosphere foundation and
other partners
and that that sort of gives us safe user
guidance
for for the estuary um
other than that i mean there has been
quite a lot of concern recently because
this year has been busier than any other
year uh
steve and myself looking at the window
here when occasionally do
we've seen more jet skis whizzing up and
down the harbour
up to the harbour in the harbour we have
more control
so from riverbank house upstream
we have more control because you have
that's the harbor area and with some
powers in the harbour area
from the estate from here from riverbank
house down to the estuary mouth
we don't so we can't um
penalize people for being silly on jet
skis
in in the estuary that's not in our
jurisdiction
that's a coast guard matter okay thanks
sean
yeah you've got uh council of laws and
councillor haynes with their hands
raised
right victor aims
um yeah point of information chair thank
you um
um i've checked with the coast guard
they don't have any powers over jet skis
um and as you know there there is a
motion that was put to council which has
gone to cnr about
banning jet skis from churchfield
slipway so
i assume sean or someone will be giving
a report
to cnr about that as to the feasibility
of banning jet skis i mean various ideas
have been knocking around but
hopefully they'll be discussed at cnr
thank you okay council of laws
guests unmute if you're going to speak
counsellor
thank you chair sorry about that um well
i think this is an
awful situation when you cast your mind
back to that horrible incident that
happened
down in cornwall with a boat running
running right
for the local council district council
to turn around and say oh no
not our responsibility and we know it's
not the responsibility of the coast
guard
whose responsibility is it and when we
come back to
the jet skis the proposal is that they
launch
from biddeford well if you look at the
plan for where jet skis can actually
um take part in their sport they'll have
to be traveling through the whole
length of the river to to reach it but i
think sean
sean we need to as counselors we need to
know
who is responsible the estuary is a huge
tourism asset to the whole area
it's well used and we need to know
about the well-being and safety of the
people who use it
and our responsibility or whose
responsibility it is
thank you jeff right sean do you want to
answer that
yes yeah of course yeah the um this i'm
sure
like has been referenced will be picked
up if the notice of motion succeeds and
is forwarded to community and resources
committee there'll be a cover and report
and i can set out what we know and what
we don't know
in amongst that we must remember though
even in some circumstances where
it would be great for something to do we
don't necessarily have to do it
ourselves
we can't take responsibility for
everything it would be a really really
risky thing to get involved in hence why
we stepped back before but this is all
part of a bigger debate
um as we move forward so i'm sure it
will be thrashed out fully at community
and resources
chair councillor hackett's also raised
his hand now yeah i i gather i'm just
trying to
shut my phone up cancel council akkit
[Music]
thank you chairman um i used to sail on
the river out of north devon yacht club
at insta
and i'm very well aware of the situation
with jet skis
the problem you've got is that we can't
act unilaterally
we would have to take north devon
district council on board with us
because these jet skis
were going all the way out to lundy with
jerry cans of fuel on the
back of the jet skis and they were
refueling and going out and coming back
so that's a
round trip of about 40 miles so
the fact that we try and inconvenience
them by
making sure they can't launch off one
slip way or another
in the scheme of things is not going to
address the major issue
it's going to have to be done with as i
said unilateral action
between both councils and even then we
might not be able to stop it
thank you chair okay sean i i can't
quite
understand how we've got onto jet skis
no i don't know other chair but
i think this is not part of qbr one
the the one thing i would just say very
quickly before we finish on jet skis
is that uh we have actually got a no jet
skis
ban in the harbor and the the slipway
that's been proposed
in the harbor of biddeford is in the no
jet skis area so
if we would kind of if we uphold no jet
skis at church for a car park we'd be up
holding
no jet skis from from any of our
slipways in the estuary
um that doesn't mean they won't get
there because they can also do the other
side of the river of course
yeah too right okay look can we move on
we're on page twenty one okay you've got
mr dengue
hand up
it was just to say that i think some of
those um oh sorry
sorry some of the history was actually
when we were looking at the
responsibility of the um we're looking
at the strategy plan for the
estuary in relation to the harbour and
what was happening there and i think
some of this continues also from there
as well
um which obviously there's been some
progress on the harbour
work but i think that was also partly
linked to the
economy and then some of it was around
greater use of leisure
which i think is also partly where
things like jet skis came in
but i think originally when we first
started this line of question
it went much more back to how we could
make the
harbor economically viable yeah yeah i
totally agree with that steve
um but i just don't understand how we
got on to this but
anyway anyway can we move on
page 21 ddc4 david
yeah question from council langford yeah
regarding the
reviewed reviewed local plan and just
for clarification is the assumption that
the travelers need would
have to be included in the local plan if
it was reviewed and updated and then
there's a
quite detailed response from don burgess
uh we're not actually proposing to read
all of it out
was that answer satisfy council langford
i suppose is the question
um yes i was just i was just trying to
understand
it it seemed to be going round and round
the houses um
and the answer answers it um
while raising another issue again that
it seems like we might have to wait for
information from the government
anyway about the planning system i
assume at this stage that
because of lockdown and things travelers
aren't particularly traveling at the
moment i don't know but
but it does answer the question yes
thank you okay happy with that shirley
yeah yes thank you okay david
okay um page 21 again yeah this is from
mr harper when will the high street
accommodation be completed and ready for
use
are there other potential properties
identified like i said again there's
quite a detailed response
from adrian redwood yeah
did that answer satisfy you mr harper
here fine thank you okay
nobody else want to ask any questions on
that
okay um
there's a question from mr harper about
the recovery of loans
yeah facebook on page for 22. yeah
yeah yeah just to um understand um
there's a quite a long detailed answer
from my colleague william batten and
also from the
housing options manager helen um
we do offer loans to people at risk of
homelessness
as generally the most efficient way of
mitigating the risk of homelessness so
we give a loan
say for a month's rent in advance
because they don't have a month's rent
to
put down on a property that's a cheaper
option than putting them in temporary
accommodation because we they can't
afford a month's rent in advance
so there's quite a high um
write-off rate of about a third but that
should be burning context of the
the other side of the equation the cost
that would be associated
with not providing the rent in advance
or the deposit on their behalf and try
to get me to see a more sustainable
tenancy
is there any other questions you had mr
harper on that response
i think it's a good response no i think
the response was excellent and that's uh
it's a it's a better solution than
paying out for people with homelessness
okay
yeah too right yeah okay dave phase 26
yeah uh this is from councillor haynes
depot relocation which other sites have
been
investigated for the environmental
center and innovation on materials that
can be collected is it feasible for the
council to collect and recycle
polystyrene
i see polyg polystyrene boxes and broken
surfboards and then the response
is uh from richard hayes our waste and
recycling manager
um does that satisfy uh council hayes
yes a good response
uh chair thank you um yeah item
one it was okay um i'm a bit
disappointed about
the response on the police staring um
it would be nice to know why torres
can't we recycle
polystyrene when um there's a reference
to south
and also be useful to have information
um about you know where where around the
public could go to
collecting that's the problem at the
moment i don't think we have the
capacity to collect
polystyrene um is that related to covid
or or do you mean because we haven't
gone facilities to process it or
all you mean the lorries vehicles or
what we haven't got
we haven't got the facilities which
hopefully
in the future we we will have the
facilities
but but that's that's probably i mean i
i was quite into it for me
on that i was quite interested to see
that uh
when these uh things get taken away to
southwest metals that in barnstable we
can beat you about the recycle
discussion broken set boards
and they get recycled into building
blocks
um yeah a lot of builders that would
love them
because they must be so light
yeah just be nice if well
by capacity do you mean that we haven't
gotten in a proper
environment center yet or what that's
right i think that's part
i think that's part to do with it you
know well
i'm sure eventually we'll be recycling a
hell of a lot more stuff
yeah it'd be nice to have clarification
from richard haste about that really
it'll be useful to put
it'll be useful to put on the website
the recycling about recycling what the
public can do you know
what where the public can go with uh
surfboard
i'm sure we can we can look into that
thank you okay
happy there let's move on then page 34
35
increase during lockdown that was a
question from mr harper and there's a
response from
richard does that satisfy you mr harper
nice excellent thank you very much some
good answers in this time mainly
yeah councillor newton has his hand
raised sorry councillor
simon uh sorry chuck now
it was actually i was just going to
comment further on that on the last
subject you were discussing
i i've had a group of my residents
who've been
uh recently making eco bricks
um and that yeah there's a there's a
website you look it up and it tells you
how to do it
and they're taking plastic bottles and
then you stuff these plastic bottles
with basically any other bits of plastic
you can get hold of
and you do it all up and then you send
it to a recycle or a
collection point in south moulton and
there's a company who then turns it into
some form of
a building block which is all fine and
good
until that system breaks down they
haven't been working during covid
i asked richard hastie whether they
could
accept built these building
blocks basically bottles filled with
with other plastic
back into the recycling system and of
course because they've got
any any number of different types of
plastic
rammed into these bottles the answer is
no because we haven't got the capacity
to disassemble all of this
um so the answer came back keep storing
them in in in your in your garden sheds
until um
the uh that the system reopens again but
yeah these things don't always work
quite as they're intended no that's fine
simon that
sounds good actually right move on then
okay we have a question from council
langford uh it's really great to have
the park hope and see that equipment has
been maintained
your safe usage so good to have the
children back on there thank you
are the upgrade improvement replacements
on hold because of kovid 19
or are they waiting for the play
strategy that's from council langford
i'll just flick on to the next screen
because he answered on the next screen
with another question so bear with me
and there's a question from mr harper
the collaboration and sharing roles with
other organizations with staff working
from home is this the way forward for
tdc and meeting the cost constraints and
delivering excellent service to the
residents of torridge
so there's a response there council
language from helen bond
um are you satisfied with that the
response yeah
uh yes thank you okay and uh mr harper
the response from sarah as our hr
manager regarding
the long-term arrangement for working
from home
fine thank you okay right
page 33 then dave yeah yeah revenue
council tax what is the predicted
increase in arrears
that's one question for me now i can
answer this um
we're expecting an increase in the
arrays of
by 1.8 million to 4 million pounds
obviously my
caveat to that is how much the increase
local council tax support claims will be
which i don't know and i'll only know
when furlough
unfolds i also don't know when we will
be able as a council to take active
recovery costs
uh action against people with overdue
councils at the moment there are no
court dates available to the council
right so taking that into account i
suspect the increase the cost of it to
the council will be 216
000 pounds is happy with the answer mr
harper
okay the next question was about paris
councils
um we've the only 30 percent of the
grant has been spent is the only
intention to collect the unspent money
is
and the answer is yes we'll recover the
unspent monies
offset it against their second payment
to town and parish presets which is due
at the end of september
and we want them to respond by the 7th
of september
with what they've spent and then we'll
take that as the point in time
which will knock off their next second
the second payment of the town of karis
precept is that
satisfactory mr harper
excellent thank you very disappointing
that parish councils have only spent 30
percent though
thanks yeah but maybe it's a reflection
anecdotally that people just did good
deeds without expecting
um reward as as that's true as
my partner did here she could have
probably claimed for petrol but
as she worked in waitrose she was
collecting food
and distributing it for people in in
clawton and
tecla and luffing and she didn't claim
any money which
is fine but yeah that's okay right
okay we do have two recommendations from
the report
um
david sorry what page are we on oh
i'm not sure i think it's just at the
end of the slide presentation i think
i'm not sure it's in the papers
we went through the um
qbr one and sure that we had a
break-even petition
position there was a recommendation to
make two contributions to reserve was
the property maintenance pressures
and for funding apprentice and trainee
pulse
obviously this needs to be taken in
light with the caveat
of any decisions that are made by the
council in terms of further support for
businesses such as free car parking
so the recommendation is we approve
these contributions to reserves but take
into account
that uh only yesterday um councillors at
cnr agreed
to recommend free car parking for two
months a potential cost to the council
72 000 pounds
steve stacy would this be a recorded
vote
yeah i don't know we're coming back
we're coming back okay you you need a a
proposer yeah i prepared something
simon simon newton proposes
our second
okay can everybody here
hello okay we just need to go to the
recorded votes then
yeah yeah mary you yeah i'm ready
cancel about him
richard cancel about wake up
four sorry four so i was
four
newton four council watson
four unanimous chair
okay thank you i think i'll stop staring
my screen now
right okay it's truth
you've got rid of it now then okay let's
have a look where we are
ethical investments who's going to take
this up then
um that's that's me peter
all right okay all right peter
go for it mate okay thank you yeah i'll
talk you through the ethical investments
briefing paper um
this um comes from members expressing an
interest back in
2017 um full council
um we then uh we had a short
appendix in the treasury management um
policy
in 2018 yeah
and then we've further explored some
options
um actually back at the end of last year
um looking into a bit more detail what
this involves
yeah so then this report gives a bit
more
a bit more background of what ethical
investments are and what the members
need to
consider um if we're to go down this
route into investing some of our
treasury management resources
in that manner so first thing is what is
an ethical investment
um and put simply generally an ethical
investment we are investing in companies
so that might take the form of shares
bonds
um or even via bank deposits
but we're generally it's limiting our
investments to
looking at companies which have ethical
values ethical policies
and operate in certain sectors possibly
renewables
green sectors um with all that in mind
um torridge and the members really we
need to sort of define our own
standard of what ethical green means to
us
and therefore what companies we would
like to
or what in what manner we'd like to
invest
this brings us on to sort of the two
main categories
ethical investments tend to be focused
into
this tends to be sort of ethically
filtered
which is sort of do no harm so it's we
don't want to invest in
oil tobacco arms
that's one sort of sector and then
ethical overlay where they're looking
more of the objectives of the company so
they might be object
towards education renewable energy
efficiency
etc so with these in mind
i think members really we have to set
our objectives of what our
what we want to invest in or our focus
is um
because especially we move down the
share route there's a lot of choices a
lot of availability in every
fund etc is slightly different
um also um as this is a treasury
related function we've got to include it
in the treasury management strategy
so we'll need to put a sort of our
objectives into that treasury management
strategy um so that
brings us on to sort of the investment
types um
as i mentioned these tend to be shares
is
is a one of the large types this could
be an individual shares but more likely
be
share funds and then the funds will have
its own rules for
how it invests whether it's specific
sectors
or the do no harm side of things
um we also have bonds so which is
basically the loans
borrow loaning money to companies
effectively
again this could be individual companies
but more likely it would be
funds so groups of bonds
within bonds you have a subsect which
they call money market funds
which really just means short dated
um bonds so short dated loans which
means they act a bit more cash they're a
bit um
a bit less lower risk but with that
comes lower returns um
and then thirdly it's bank deposits so
treasury deposit deposits
um these are quite new in the market um
so they
generally it's what we do at the moment
is treasury deposits so we put money
with lloyds or barclays
but now some of these banks have started
offering
green treasury deposits so what they're
saying is the money you put with us will
only use to invest in
green or ethical companies but
that's quite a small sector of the
market at the moment there's not a lot
a lot to it um so within all this we
have to look at the treasury
management impact um and treasury
management really it's
we're always focused on security
liquidity then yield
in that order so our security is uh
paramount liquidity is important because
we need you need quick access to the
money generally because we're generally
looking more short term
and yield is always important but
is the least important of the three um
now with that in mind
there's a reason we don't tend to invest
at the moment in shares and bonds
because they're
higher risk there so the security isn't
is lower and they're much more volatile
so
although the returns are better um
earlier in the year
you know the market dropped 20 so if you
needed the money at that point then you
you're going to
take a big loss
we then have the treasury deposits
um which is effective what we do at the
moment so at the moment we just invest
in
place money with um the big banks at the
moment our treasury
policy allows uk f1 rated banks
um some of these have started to offer
the green deposits i said but they'll
probably be
some yield um sacrifice or
so you probably get slightly less money
investing in a green
deposit than you would just as a regular
deposit
um so we kind of have to think about
what what yield we would be willing to
to give up so you know the cost to the
council that will be willing
to actually sacrifice to know that it's
going in ethical and green
investments um also money market funds
um
they're worth a separate mention just
because uh lots of councils do invest in
these these tend to be
they're sure they're very short dated
bonds so they tend to be instant access
so you can get your money quick
there's a slightly higher risk than just
in banks
but they tend to be less risky because
of the short dated
amount but again the returns sort of
reflect that as well there'll be lower
returns
um so the next thing is the benefit and
risks table which is in the presentation
that sort of highlights
a little bit of what i've just been
saying it's the shares and bonds
the share and bond funds will give
increased returns
um over the last few years probably
looking at sort of six percent a year
um but history isn't necessarily a guide
to the future and
that the market can drop significantly
so the risk
the risk is there um because of that
generally if we were investing in the
longer term
um higher risk then we would want to be
doing it for the medium to longer term
which is probably three to five years
and actually a lot of our money at the
moment
is probably more shorter we need it more
for the
three to six months um
that length of time leaves a sort of
lack of flexibility for us
um as well um can't utilize it for some
of the capital program depending on the
timings of that
um the green treasury deposits money
market funds
they're more flexible but the the return
is less so we always
you know the yield is lower although
that is our least
um important factor it's still
still a factor to consider
um over so overall i just uh
i'd also summarize that our treasury
resources that we have at the moment
that are sort of changing
over the last couple of years um over
the last few years we've had quite a
large capital um reserves so we've had
quite a bit of money to put
put away on deposit earnings interest um
because we've got some bigger projects
coming up like the depot
um like the future high streets fund
there's some
debt that we've been authorised to
borrow um so we've got to
always take in consideration that if
we're borrowing on one hand to fund
these projects
should we really be investing large sums
of money for the long term
out elsewhere so you've got to weigh up
those pros and cons
um so so the more of our
the majority of our the rest of our
money is more short-term it's because we
collect council tax over 10 months
um and we pay out over a year so we tend
to have
excess cash from sort of the summer
through to january
so we tend to put that away but that's
obviously short term because we need it
in
february march um just to pay the normal
bills
um that effectively takes on to the next
steps which is
really where do we go from here and what
members have to discuss and decide
um and that's sort of again so it's
summarizing a lot of what i've already
said which is
need to set those ethical invest
objectives
um what they'd like to exclude what they
don't want to invest in
oil tobacco location at the moment we're
in the uk
allowed treasury-wise to invest in uk
banks whereas actually a lot of
companies shares they can be overseas
they can be worldwide
even if they're on the uk markets and if
we have specific goals what sectors we
would like to
focus on whether it's renewable green
education
so once we when we set those objectives
we then we need to
identify objectives um and that's
actually quite
quite difficult as in there's a lot of
funds out there
um not so much on the treasury deposit
side it's a smaller market but generally
general funds there's there's a lot of
different choice out there and they all
have slightly different rules so so i
think we probably need a member group or
meeting
um to be able to select specific
investments
um and also we need to set up the limits
and the
by investment type almost so green
treasury deposits are actually quite
similar to what we do at the moment so
you might want to say
yes we want to vote we're happy
happy to go down that line as long as
there's not too much of a cost to the
council finance
from a yield perspective but the share
and bond funds
are very different and need approving by
the members and full council um and
maybe set limits on what we
um invest in so whether that's you know
a few hundred thousand
or or a couple of million but
set that so we know exactly how much
we've got really
and then all this needs to sort of um
end up in the sort of as an ethical
statement on the treasury
management strategy um which will need
approving at full council
and that's the end really in summary so
um any questions okay
any questions for peter hang on one
minute peter um
councillor ames you've got you've got
your hand up yeah
thank you chair um thank you very much
for the full
um reports um
presentation um i just want to first of
all
um do we uh where do we have
you haven't indicated where the council
invests its money
and um whether there are possibilities
for invest
changing over to funds within our
present investments
at the moment we're not authorized we're
not authorized by the council to invest
in funds
so at the moment we're just allowed to
do short-term deposits with uk banks
which have a f1 rated so not allowed to
do
any investments um in shares or bond
funds at all
so it's sort of something which would
need to be um authorized by the members
to do
yeah i mean i noted with sort of alarm
really that this was first proposed in
2017
and it was actually approved that we
should invest ethically i don't know
whether it was a full
council or what but i don't know why
nothing has happened since then
but i think certainly we need to
start looking at ethical green ethical
investments now
in common with other councils and to
recognize that
a lot of the green funds produce just as
good or better returns than
non-green
yeah i mean how we actually progress
this now
whether we i mean are deciding you know
that we do want to
to go ahead with this i mean it's not a
question already whether we decide to go
ahead because as i've said in 2017
we actually took a decision to do so so
to look at it not to do it
um ethical i'm sure it was
to look at it not to do it chase like a
mark
yeah you better come back into it yeah
chair so it's been raised a couple of
times at full council when i presented
the treasury management statement
to full council and whilst it was
discussed a number of times
there was never a recommendation to
actually do anything
other than to have a look at some of the
things which internal scrutiny did
um at one time and didn't make any
recommendations to change anything
so it's been just it's been discussed
a number of times at full council but
other than that nothing's been formally
taken forward
as there is no formal decision in place
thank you well i'd like guidance really
where we go
now are we going to write i personally
would like to propose that we
um investigate further ethical
investments um
and to direct the um
analysis and appraisal to the
appropriate committee i mean i don't
know whether it should be
the recently formed climate work
member climate work group or whether it
should be a
special group set up but
i i wish to recommend that we move
forward on this really
and to look at the various types of
accounts which have been
highlighted if i can come back on that
so what happened previously
was it was picked up at the income
generation working group so you already
have
um a working group or task and finish
group in place
any recommendations from that group
would come back to this committee
and would form part of an overall
recommendation to full campuses any full
council that can change
the treasury management strategy
so if if members wanted to discuss it
further it could be discussed further
through the
income generation group and then brought
back
any any recommendations to the committee
to make
recommendation chain recommendation
changes
to the council's treasury management
strategy
okay okay
thank you chair yes well steve's um
said it already that i wanted to say
really because we need to delve down in
this a bit deeper because on page 47
we need to define what we we
we want in the first place just because
the ethical
it means you know what sort of ethical
categories we we step into and i was
going to suggest
and i will propose that we take it to
the task and finish group
yeah and uh um i don't do
i think i sit on that should i use you
as well chair i don't do
elvis on it but i think that's where we
need to put this
at the moment because we need to delve
into this a bit deeper
to know exactly what we what we are
proposing as a counselor
yeah okay tony we can we can do that
stephen dengay thank you chair um when
we last looked at this i think one of
the questions was raised
was how much actually free element of
the treasury management was available
for investment
because it was obviously call on that so
it's it's around duration
the longest element of the duration of
the treasury management
funds that we're looking at when it
comes to investment so if it's under
five years it makes it much more
constrained than if it's say
seven years or even further i'm not sure
we ever quite
fully got a feeling of what the element
of investment
capital was there that we could use to
invest in something
like an ethical and i think the other
thing that we looked at
and and talked about that i don't think
we quite got to was
actually coming up with an overarching
investment policy
of which the ethical element will form
part of that but that includes your
overall
security liquidity and return on
investment
for the whole portfolio as well as the
cash element
so i think there were a few bits that we
kind of were
looking at but never quite landed on but
if there isn't a lot of money free to
invest then
you know it could be a lot of work for
for something that doesn't have a lot of
um
mileage mileage in it yeah that's true
thanks steven um simon
i was just gonna really reiterate uh
what uh tony inch said and and
say that it's absolutely essential to
quantify what it is you're trying to
achieve uh and at the risk of us
offending some
but there's a lot of very general broad
brush statements in this in this
world uh referencing ethical and all
things to do with chewing lentils
normally
which um is is absolutely
um we've got to be very careful where we
go
uh on this and it's got to be really
drilled down with really
clear detail i mean for instance i just
pick up one you've got
defense here or armament or whatever the
south west is a huge
employer in that area are we actually
saying that we're not
we don't want to invest in that area and
you know
successive governments um do et cetera
so
what's just got to be um there's got to
be a lot of detail
uh in in this and we're probably i'd
have thought talking more green than
anything else
um yeah but um that would be my point
that whoever
whoever it goes to i don't know the
system uh
there's a lot of work to actually just
quantify exactly
and bring back to council for approval
as to what
what is it that you know we want to we
want to go to um
it's a first thing thanks okay simon
councillor ames
yeah thank you chair um do we know when
the task and finish group
meets next please sorry when does the
task and finish group
meet next please we haven't decided yet
but i'm sure we will i'm sure councils
don't need reminding that we committed
to a climate emergency
and ethical investment green investments
are part of that
um as for lentil chewing um most of the
big corporations i gather
are disinvesting from fossil fuels as a
start
so it's not just um you know the win the
extreme wing of the green movement
that's talking about this
this is becoming becoming more and more
central well
our last call closed down last week yeah
good yeah as i said i know i suspect
green is that i have no problems with
with you know
uh looking specifically at a green
agenda you're absolutely right but
um uh otherwise you end up not and of
course our
overriding responsibility is to minimize
risk to taxpayer money um
so there are limits whatever we want to
go
can i just ask about pensions chair did
i hear something earlier about
um a review of pensions is this to do
i mean like is is it nest that is the
pensions provider for public services or
can
can i ask you steve through you chair
about that
is well i can understand that yes i
can't remember hearing anything about
pensions but
do you want to answer steven
it was a question raised by a councillor
at audit
and governance committee about where um
peninsula pension so the pension funds
for
uh most of southwest councils are
invested
so we've got the assistant county
treasurer mark
gaylor coming to a future audit and
governance committee meeting
to explain how pension funds are
invested i think one of the biggest
problems we've had over the years
is actually coming up with that
definition
of what's ethical because ethical
one person might not be to another so
you've got to come up with
something that all members at full
council
are satisfied meets their collective
definition of ethical now we've talked
about different
arms firms and oil and all sorts now if
you think
most of the big oil companies you
probably wouldn't
consider them to be green but they
invest
far more than most other organization
now in green energy so there's lots of
um issues and things to think about
now the other thing as councillor newton
pointed out security of our funds are
paramount
so i suspect we won't have very much to
invest
anyway because if you think about david
hayes's slide
earlier where he showed the cash flows
we having we'll have less and less to
invest so as one of the councillors
mentioned
we could end up doing quite a
considerable amount of work
for very little gain so that you know we
have to
bear that in mind as well we can we
we can bring up the the the task and
finish group we can bring that back
steve can't we
um yes jay you've got a proposal from
counselor inch to take this
to the task and finish group and um yes
you can arrange that meeting if
if that's seconded and yeah
i'll second that okay do we i don't
think we need to vote do we
if it's um jay i've got a formal
recommendation really
other than to hold a task and finish
group meeting so it doesn't need a form
of recommendation
we cannot we can organize that we can
organize a meeting
that's not a problem okay
any more questions
[Applause]
i don't know sorry joe will that then
task and finish will that then come back
to us will it yes
it is our tuscan finish group all right
okay yep thanks
all right if you wish to sit on it you
can sit on it
it's fine oh can we all sit on that then
sure
no oh thank you yeah
we we need to have a small room yeah
hello
yes chair uh sorry sorry boss
yeah steve joe it might be worth
uh thinking about as the as the group
hasn't met for some time
um whether you want um i can't i think
the only members on the group were
if i recall yourself your vice chair
and one other member so it may be
worthwhile considering
who you wished or want volunteers to sit
on that task and finish group
as it's a single specific item i
volunteer and then we can ask
okay we'll go with chair vice chair and
i mean tony inch was on it before
tony unmute
thank you chair yes i yeah but provided
provided that
you know you can get to the meetings
tony that
that'd be fine mate yeah okay
that's fine chair you're frozen i think
chair
listen i'm i'm i'm all right
jack can you did you hear me tony
yes i answered your chair i said yes
that's okay okay
all right okay that's fine though right
uh stephen stephen dengay where are you
yeah right yeah
i mean we're coming to on the full plan
but just before we move off
ethical investment we it might be worth
looking to
the task and finish group looking at it
as a environmental and social governance
because it takes it not just on the
ethical element
and i know that might be broadening the
base too far but
there are elements about governance
around
direct investments that you might want
to do as well okay but i think it would
be really helpful
and without creating too much work for
the officers if we could
at least have an idea of what the
longest duration of the deposits
are currently because as steve says
you know we could be talking about a
very small amount of money
for a not very long period which would
have quite a big impact
on what decisions you took around
investing anyway
so it would be worth knowing what the
longest duration on
treasury deposit is that we hold and how
much that is
i'm sure when it comes back off holiday
he can it can sort that out can't you
sleep
yeah i think that the current policy
doesn't allow for anything beyond
um a year i think that's right if
we did we did go through all this before
a lot but okay we will sort out a
meeting
and steve will have one or two of the uh
questions answered
okay we'll do that
right everybody don't shout at once
that's fine right
onto uh forward plan now aren't we
yep forward plan
that's fine right let me just move that
out the way
right okay september september meeting
review of treasury investment
options
hello over there
okay i think i think that was originally
only for that meeting but it's
kind of brought forward to today's
meeting yeah it'll depend
whether the group meets and
have enough information to report back
but you can leave it on there
if you change anything to the treasury
management strategy we usually do that
in february or march for the company for
the year
um leading into anyway so you've got
plenty of time leading up to
finding yeah up to that
so yeah i mean then in november if we
come on to qbr too
that should give us a bigger insight of
what we what we've done since
this one anyway um the september meeting
could have something else on which might
take take a while um
but yeah um we'll just i think we'll
just
anybody want to put anything on
forward plan sure just
what peter um review of treasury
investment options did i hear steve say
you could wait till february before they
report about that
steve did you say that sorry council
james i didn't quite catch up then
did you say were you referring to the
report from tuscan finish on treasury
investments or just generally sorry
not quite i think i think that was
originally on the agenda and we've just
reported
that back at this meeting and what i
said you could have a report just
an update from the task and finish group
the september meeting crisis i suspect
it won't be in a
position to be finalized um within
kind of five weeks okay that's fine
steve
so i thought you said that otherwise we
would wait till february
is that you didn't say that sorry sorry
yeah i thought you oh i thought you said
if we didn't get anything september we
could wait till february
sorry i was referring to is we take
an annual treasury management strategy
um in february for the for the financial
year that leads into so in february 2021
we'll be producing the strategy for 21
22. right um so what i was suggesting is
this piece of work would feed
into that report in february all right
sorry
thanks any more questions
uh anybody did i see somebody with a
hand up
no um anything anybody would like to
have put on the forward plan
i have i have maybe got something for
september so
um i can only say that later
um okay
hello all right well we'll go with the
forward plan as it is
and and then obviously in september
we'll look at what's happening in
november
okay everybody happy
yeah can i just ask you yeah it's a very
small thing
but um sorry do you know what time
the the one in september will be well
i mean it's is everybody happy with this
time
oh or would everybody be happy to go
back to 10 o'clock
you may this this this time suits me
fine
if you go to 10 o'clock i won't no no
it's fine i i'm
you know it's fine so yeah
yeah yeah jude you all right yeah i'm
fine i'm unemployed now so
anyway all right okay so yeah we'll keep
it we'll keep you to two o'clock then
yeah
thank you all fine with me i don't get
up until 11.
crikey i've done a day's work by 11.
oh dear hallelujah in chic hallelujah
oh anyway um that's kind of finished
with tom can you get us off
tom yeah i'm just doing it for your
chair